a group of cops tried to break up a holy
week
service in canada a few days ago the
pastor of that church
did not take very kindly to their visit
go out and don't come back to you
[Music]
immediately out i don't care what you
have to say
out out out of this property or nazis
out
is not allowed here immediately gestapo
is not
allowed out
do you understand english get out of
this property
go so go go and don't come back without
the warrant
out nazi out out
you understand nazis are not welcome
here out
and don't come back without a warrant do
not come back without a warrant you
understand that
you're not welcome here nazis are not
welcome here
gestapo is not welcomed here do not come
back you nazi
psychopaths unbelievable
sick evil people
intimidating people in a church during
the passover
i love him i want to make him an
honorary american what has gone wrong in
our country
that americans need to take lessons on
freedom
and religion from canadians i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the michael
knowles show to check out the full
episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you